so there was uh there was an improv
class and i thought yeah improv sure
wait they had an improv class back in in
seventies in yes
no they it's at suny brockport they had
a big theater department
uh which so i thought i had to take one
fine arts course to graduate you had to
have one
and i thought
improv sure yeah let's let's go improv
class
took the improv class teacher's name was
sally rubin and she was
she was a hippie no doubt about it right
and
true story it was like
maybe a month into the class and
she asked me one day can you stick
around and want to talk to you after and
i thought yeah i hope i didn't do
anything she likes you baby yeah so i
waited after class and she said shut the
door she came over sat down and she said
listen um
i really think you should do this
and i was like
what
and she goes no i'm i'm serious i've
been doing this for a long time and i i
really
you just you know how to listen
you know how to be in a moment and uh
i just don't think you can
you could teach that and
just think about it and i'm like i mean
that's like saying to me you know you
want to go to mars and i'm like
it was so foreign to you
so completely foreign and i said
wow and then i asked her
she said you should you know maybe think
about taking more classes because you
know you have two years left your junior
year and senior year so i found out that
you couldn't take the other acting
classes unless you were a theater major
but she went to the department head and
said i got a guy in my class and uh
i'd like you to meet him and allow him
to take other classes and so i i met him
the department chair for the theater
department he said okay and he let me
take
other theater classes so all my
electives then i just took these theater
classes wow and and it's not like
theater departments are like super
welcoming
no you know super clicky a lot of clicks
super clicky they were not interested in
me my hair was you know way over my
shoulders i i left class i went to the
gym i got a
12 pack and it just was not my groove
but i didn't care
because i like the teachers and i like
the experience if she doesn't call you
in
her room and say
says something you know she doesn't say
something to you about your improv
skills or your listening or i think you
should take this seriously you don't do
this is that right i don't i i
i mean i look at it as such it's such a
pivotal like turning point like one of
those moments you have in your life we
all have them and you think
am i
wow you know
if if somewhere inside of my head i was
entertaining that you know that like boy
wouldn't that be something special you
know a little confirmation
is can make all the difference in the
world
and and i had that with her